[Aplausos]
blandiendo banderas rusas chechenas y
soviéticas se oye a estos combatientes
decir que han entrado en y si sans que
los vídeos fueron publicados en telegram
por ramzán kadyrov el líder de chechenia
y un aliado clave de vladimir putin los
vídeos corroboran las afirmaciones
hechas por rusia el viernes
las fuerzas armadas rusas siguen
avanzando con éxito en la región del isi
tanks en los últimos tres días se ha
establecido el control sobre una planta
de procesamiento de combustible una mina
y una fábrica de gelatina el ejército
ucraniano está sufriendo grandes
pérdidas en esta región
el sábado un portavoz separatista dijo
que el isi suns que estaba completamente
rodeada afirmaciones que fueron negadas
al instante por quien los combates se
libran en los alrededores del isi chance
pero afortunadamente la ciudad no ha
sido cercada y está bajo control del
ejército ucraniano mientras rusia
intensifica sus ataques contra la ciudad
muchos residentes ya habían hundió
la ciudad ya no existe ha sido
prácticamente borrada de la faz de la
tierra
ningún centro de distribución de ayuda
humanitaria ha sido golpeado
y
muchas víctimas yo fui una de ellas
estaba cubierta de escombros la gente me
ayudó a desenterrar me el domingo el
ministro ruso de defensa anunció
finalmente la liberación total de la
región de lugansk tras la toma de
decisións la última gran ciudad que
seguía bajo control ucraniano en la
región su conquista ahora abre las
posibilidades para el ejército ruso a
avanzar hacia su avance y crematorios
otras dos grandes ciudades del donbass
que moscú tiene en el punto de mira